le thermomètre va chauffer cette semaine
en france il s'agit d'un épisode de
canicule sévère voire très sévère les
autorités ont déclenché le niveau 3 du
plan canicule
c'est le dernier avant l'alerté maximale
qui veut dire que la chaleur ressentie
va être bien supérieure à la température
affichée par le thermomètre est donc
l'inconfort sera supérieure à 20 confort
de 2030
durant l'été 2003 la france et toute
l'europe en suffoquer la vague de
chaleur sans précédent a touché dix pays
sécheresse accrue feux de forêt et un
bilan des plus lourds
soixante dix mille morts en europe dont
15000 en france cette fois c'est aussi
la précocité de la canicule qui inquiète
pour atteindre des niveaux de
température pendant environ six jours
peut-être même sept jours qui n'ont
jamais été observées pour un mois de
juin à paris c'est déjà la ruée vers les
fontaines et les plans d'eau
dans un appartement parisien exprimant
thématisation donc on série de
ventilateurs pour ces touristes venus
des îles des caraïbes la bouteille d'eau
est indispensable elle s'hydratent
constamment ce touriste en bien trouve
qui fait plus frais dans son pays qu'à
paris ailleurs en europe les
recommandations sont les mêmes
boire beaucoup d'eau se couvrir la tête
éviter les efforts physiques en pleine
journée au sud et au centre de l'espagne
risque d'incendié est extrême les pays
scandinaves et le royaume unis
s'inquiètent des risques d'orages
violents
ici à ce mitraillage radio canada
montréal